so your strategy with amateur
transitioning into mannchild a feature
mm-hmm what's on deck what do you have
planned right you know the strategy of
releasing amateur free online is really
about other than it being a long time
since I've released a film that I
directed and just you know sort of
having that that that feeling of my god
good this thing is out there and you
know I feel like that is worth a lot
right there but but really the strategy
is reaching the sports world and the
basketball world you know this is a
story that I think hasn't been told
before I'm talking about the feature and
I think there's a lot of interest in
that as far as you know there's an
ongoing suit against the NCAA from
something acara about our shouldn't
college athletes be paid you know I
think a lot people don't know how young
the recruiting has gotten a lot of
basketball players have gone through
this themselves a lot of hooks in the
basketball world so the reason that I
released it free online was to reach
that world and we're gonna be we're
gonna be releasing on YouTube and making
sort of a second a second launch for the
short to that end and I would just say
that you know for anybody who's anybody
who's watching this if you have you know
sports or basketball connections you
know I think those are the people that
are really trying to get it in front of
so email me at Ryan at manchild film
calm and you know I think really what
you know to sort of talk about what
we're doing no film school that's the
site exists for everybody to be helping
each other and I think the site is gonna
be more of that going forward as we
redesign and you know it's amazing
putting this out there and hearing from
other filmmakers in the community people
saying hey I know this guy there get in
touch with him like I've met great
people that way and you know the lesson
has been that cold emails basically just
go to nowhere and I get cold emails all
the time just you know the option to
that is that I know how to write them at
least you know I'm not writing
ten paragraphs and trying to make things
very easy on people when I'm still not
hearing back so that's kind of the
challenge but the great thing about the
filmmaking community is that oh this guy
who is that guy and they pass it on and
people really like your short and then
things are in motion because of that so
you know releasing amateur online has
been just another example of sort of the
community and the networking making
something possible and hopefully you
know at the at the end of the day that's
gonna be what makes this this feature
get made
not just the crowdfunding and the
Kickstarter and then to a film school
audience but also just filmmakers
talking to each other and helping each
other out is really that's really what
my side is all about and hopefully you
know at the end of the day man shot will
be a good example of that too
you